Mission Incredible or Mission unbearable
here's the best and worst of Tom
Cruise's greatest action franchise
first of all it's worth pointing out
that being the worst in an indisputably
phenomenal franchise isn't such a bad
thing it's not that director John Woo's
submission to the IMF compendium is bad
per se it's just that it doesn't hold a
candle to the other five films the movie
pairs Tom Cruise's Ethan Hunt with
professional Thief Naya Hall as they
battle her ex-boyfriend who also happens
to be a rogue IMF agent the Baddie in
this one is attempting to steal a deadly
virus and start a worldwide pandemic a
plot line that has arguably aged better
than anyone could have guessed at the
time either way Mission Impossible 2 is
not the strongest of the series and it
would be six years before Ethan chose to
accept his next mission
yes the stunt on the Burj Khalifa is
cool nobody's denying that but that
scene doesn't make up for Paula Patton's
painful turn as Jane or Jeremy renner's
unbearably whiny Brandt if it wasn't for
his wife's cracking buddy Benji Ethan
might have thought about scrapping the
entire team and starting fresh after
Ghost Protocol but In fairness director
Brad Bird's Franchise entry does an
excellent job of setting up the
so-called dashies the most recent three
films in the franchise which take a
decidedly cooler approach than the three
that preceded them
[Music]
the major set pieces lose a little
urgency when you're watching them on a
small screen but All Is Forgiven for the
movie's most thrilling moment Benji
inciting a Russian prison riot against
his better judgment for example or he
and Ethan using virtual reality trickery
to break into the Kremlin that's the IMF
we all know and love
there's nothing quite like an original
or at least an adaptation of the real
original if nothing else though the
existence of the Mission Impossible TV
series just goes to show that the party
never starts until Tom Cruise shows up
it's hard to overstate the impact of
Mission Impossible when it debuted in
1996. this was a movie that killed off
half the cast in the first half hour
delivered a stealth scene so iconic it
would be parodied for years to come and
of course introduced a new generation to
an iconic theme song Perhaps a good
example of how the first of the
franchise shook the status quo is the
fact that audiences were originally
baffled some even angry at how
complicated and confusing the plot was
if you re-watch it today however you'll
experience a storyline that feels as
elegant as it is easy to follow
the top three Mission Impossible movies
are a little trickier to parse because
honestly they're all great Mission
Impossible 3 by director JJ Abrams
marked the end of one era and the
beginning of another every Mission
Impossible is bigger and Bolder than the
last but the films that follow this one
scale up considerably in terms of stunts
scope and storytelling Mission
Impossible 3 sets up that change just
right introducing us to Ethan Hunt's
foray into domestic life and bringing
back crowd favorite Luther establishing
that for Ethan Hunt people matter more
than Politics as such the film also
kicks off a question hunt will be
attempting to answer for the next three
flicks how can he save the world and the
people he cares about the movie was the
lowest grossing of the franchise and
reviews were mixed but standout
performances by Carrie Russell and
Philip Seymour Hoffman suggest it's a
lot better than it was given credit for
oh well that was nothing that was
fun
moreover it's a joy to see all the
emotional themes that were established
in this movie and carried on by the rest
Ethan Hunt as a mentor Ethan Hunt as a
man in love Ethan Hunt as a team player
and an all-around good guy all in all a
retrospective viewing gives the third
installment a shine that critics might
not have seen when it premiered in 2006.
Mission Impossible Fallout is the most
recent film of the franchise and it
picks up where its predecessor Rogue
Nation left off Ethan Hunt and the Gang
are still hot on the heels of The
Syndicate a shadowy organization
composed of former field operatives who
have since become mercenaries a new
version of The Syndicate called the
Apostle has wacky ideas about plutonium
dirty bombs and suffering leading to a
New World Order among other things none
of this really matters though because if
you're watching Fallout you're probably
on board with whatever the IMF is up to
these days many favorite faces return in
Fallout but new additions to the cast
such as Henry Cavill and Angela Bassett
make the film even more fun the movie
feels like a genuine roller coaster ride
with non-stop action breathless ups and
downs and a few loop-de-loops thrown in
for good measure it's this movie that
makes you realize that no matter how
far-fetched or implausible these flicks
might get you're always in good hands
with Christopher Macquarie and Tom
Cruise
picking a favorite in the mission
impossible series is difficult but not
altogether impossible case in point
Rogue Nation not only does this movie
introduce Alec Baldwin and Sean Harris
the latter of whom is arguably the
franchise's best villain but Christopher
Macquarie takes the whole series from
good to Great gentlemen this is Solomon
Lane
Mr Lane
meet the IMF the Quarry knows you can't
just stack cool fight scenes on top of
one another so he uses clever jokes
stunning visuals and well-written
characters to create a house of cards so
perfect you'll be holding your breath
and praying it doesn't all come crashing
down Tom Cruise cements the movie of
course with the same Charisma that one
hearts in the first film but what knocks
Rogue nation into the top spot is
Rebecca Ferguson who makes her franchise
debut with the character of ilsa Faust
Faust is more than a match for hunt and
she steals every scene she's in throw it
all together and you've got the best
Mission Impossible movie though with
Macquarie and crew set to return for
dead reckoning this one may not be in
the top spot for long